I get the chance to talk to students a
lot Oh types of students from all over
the world and often I'm talking about
math and science and I say something
that usually surprises people
I will tell students and other people
that I get goose bumps doing math I
always have even as a kid I loved doing
math problems
well people sometimes say well how'd
that happen
and I tell a story you know we all are
the products of our childhood
experiences things that happen to us as
kids and I was very fortunate to have
really wonderful parents who enjoyed
reading to me when I was a very little
kid and I started reading very early and
loved the reading well somehow my
parents decided they wanted to see how
to connect the reading to playing with
with money and with objects involving
math and before I knew it when I was
fairly very young I was solving math
word problems involving money loving it
loving it understanding that if I had
three dimes and my dad had two quarters
and we put all of our money together
that we'd have 80 cents and learning
later on that that was the same as 80
percent of a dollar or that it was eight
over ten and and so all of a sudden I
began to see how language and math came
together but I also began to understand
how you could think about math and
anything that you do if you look at the
number of people in a room if you look
at the weight of people if you look at
the room itself and you come to
understand shapes and you see rectangles
and squares and you think about the area
in a room and the perimeter all these
terms that you hear in some in some
class in geometry or in algebra and and
for me what was interesting was most
students didn't like math and in class
as a little kid I would watch other
students either being bored or
frustrated because they weren't were not
understanding the problem and so I did
something that that was especially
helpful to me in deciding what I wanted
to do for the rest of my life I began to
tutor kids I began to get
really excited about the idea that maybe
I could help somebody else to understand
the problem or to grasp a concept or to
get excited about the work I wanted more
people excited about math because I just
thought it was fun and and what became
clear to me was that it was much harder
to explain something to another student
than it was simply for me to understand
it myself
and aha then I realized here's my
challenge I have to figure out how to
use language that is so clear and simple
that I can explain a concept because I
understand the concept myself well and I
can get somebody else not only to
understand whatever it is the teacher is
talking about but then to help that
student learn how to solve the problem
and to develop confidence because what
was also clear was that because I'd had
exposure to math at home and reading and
because I was always solving math
problems I was getting better and better
and and the lesson there was we learned
to do by doing I found that the more I
read the better Arita I became and the
more I enjoyed reading quite frankly the
more reading I did the same thing in
mathematics when a student seems to feel
less than confident about the math it
usually is because they've gotten
confused by a problem or have not had
success and so all of a sudden by the
time I was 13 I was in a special math
program at a university for the summer
and the professor came into the class
this was at Tuskegee and it was a
National Science Foundation program for
smart kids in math and all of us said
first of all I realized I wasn't the
smartest person in the world that there
were a lot of people who had done even
more than I had and I was inspired by
that but the professor came in and he
put a math problem on the board and we
all looked at it and nobody could solve
it and he said see me when you can solve
it and he left and people were really
frustrated because they were thinking I
mean the teachers supposed to help you
solve the problem and his point was no
you work on it and I found myself less
frustrated and much more fascinated
because
what he was saying was I had the ability
if I really worked on it to solve that
problem even though I didn't have a clue
abut about how to do it and so we spent
days working on this problem in
statistics and what I learned was that
even though we didn't get the complete
answer we learned so much in struggling
with the issue well the reason math is
so fascinating to me in general is that
it teaches you to look at problem a
problem from different perspectives and
not necessarily to be so frustrated
because you find yourself not able to
solve it
I also found as I went through college
quite frankly was that math was at the
foundation of all the other sciences and
engineering wherever you're going to
study chemistry or physics even when you
look at something like accounting you
know from my point of view the problems
in those areas are really applied math
problems in engineering quite frankly or
in physics and and so I realized that
math became somewhat of a gatekeeper to
many other areas and I took my interest
in helping other people to do math and
my understanding of the relationship
between math and other disciplines as a
sign for me to think about really
focusing on teaching math and then to
focus on helping more students to become
interested in math and science and
engineering and what happened as I got
older was this I began to realize that
many of the problems that we faced in in
our world not just in our country
whether they're problems involving
economics and the understanding that the
challenges we faced with with financial
situations in America all we're looking
at the probability that we'll see
certain kinds of environmental issues in
different countries all we're thinking
about health disparities that often such
areas as statistics and math will be
very important because the scientists
and the engineers use the tools of math
in solving problems well I'm at a
university that really enjoys seeing
students excel and about half of our
students are in math science and
engineering and what is especially in
important to think about when you when
you think about producing students who
will become scientists is that for any
student being able to do well in math in
high school and then in college will
determine in large part the ability of
that student to become a physician or an
engineer or a scientist but also an
accountant as I said or an economist or
somebody in the business world wherever
you go more and more you're gonna see
people in mathematics or people with
math backgrounds if you think about
people in the social sciences if you're
interested in things involving sociology
or psychology again the quantitative
methods piece will be very important
because we don't solve problems and draw
conclusions based on anecdotal
information we really do need to be able
to look at data for example and analyze
it and use statistical measures and look
at the average and look at the the
highest frequency or look at the
probability that something will happen
and more and more as people become these
different professions whether it is in
the social sciences or the Natural
Sciences or engineering they see the
importance of mathematics what's been
fascinating to me over the past 40 years
is to understand that even in my work as
an administrator at a college as
president of University of Maryland
Baltimore County UMBC math comes in
handy every day in the work that I do
whether talking about issues involving
the budgets or looking at what we call
analytics how you go about analyzing
trends in and what's happening at the
University and even when I think about
trying to encourage people to go into
different disciplines let me give you an
example we worked heavily with the
National Security Agency a lot of my
students are interested in intelligence
work and defense and NSA said to us we
need you to help us produce more
mathematicians of all kinds because this
will be very important to have people
from different perspectives people of
all races people of all ethnicities who
know enough math that they can be
involved in helping to serve the country
there's nothing more noble I think then
serving one's country or saving a life
or work
the problems that can help life to be
better for all of us and what I found is
that when working with NSA and talking
with students the first thing they'll
say is well how will I use the math and
when students get chances to have
internships and to work in places around
the country but in the the science and
technology infrastructure of the country
places like the National Institutes of
Health NASA or the National Security
Agency all of a sudden they begin to see
how the math and science they've had in
their classes will relate to the real
world and for me explaining that
foundation of math for all these areas
has always been exciting now what I tend
to do when I'm talking to students
whether they are 11 or 20 is to give
them a math problem if you're going to
talk about math why not simply give
people on that problem here is an
example of the problem I would give and
what I always tell students is don't
answer immediately I want you to take
the time to think about it the problem
says this and remember as I give you
this math problem I'm getting goosebumps
goosebumps 29 children are in a class 20
have dogs 15 have cats
how many have both a dog and a cat I
actually found that problem in the
Baltimore Sun and it was saying that
many teachers and others were having
problems with it well for most people
even people who like math you'll find
that they'll want to give you an answer
quickly and the fact is that most of the
time that answer is not correct what has
to happen is from my perspective is that
the teacher or whoever's working with
you on the problem has to say well draw
it and the first thing people will do if
they've had algebra is to give me Venn
diagrams right and I'm saying I don't
want Venn diagrams I want you to see the
children the dogs and the cats because I
want people to understand that math can
be related to real life in a way that it
helps to explain the world and so if you
can see three rows 10 with kids sub with
dogs another 10 kids with dogs and then
and then put down the other nine kids
and then look at how the cats relate to
that what you'll have to see because I'm
not going to give you the
is that it takes strong thinking skills
it takes patience and it takes the
ability to understand how one thing to
next to another the foundation for me in
math thinking skills reading skills the
importance of language having the
patience to look at the problem from
different perspectives I can't think of
any profession that's more interesting
more fascinating than mathematics thank
you
you